-Leslie, you're not afraid
to speak your mind
and you always give great
advice, so I thought, right now,
you could help some people
with their big life decisions.
It's time for
"Life Coach with Leslie Jones."
Here we go.
-♪ "Life Coach
with Leslie Jones" ♪
-Ah! Very nice.
So, we asked viewers at home
to send in questions
that they need your coaching on.
You ready to give out
some tough advice?
-I am so ready.
-Alright, here we go.
This first question is...
-Absolutely!
-Really? Wow.
-Now, this is how
you need to handle this.
You sit them down and go,
"Listen, we've been here before,
the whole family.
We've been here before.
Twice, it didn't work.
So what we're going to do is,
if you make it two months,
we'll buy you a present."
-[ Laughs ] Yes!
That's exactly right.
Just two months.
-Even if the present
is a damn divorce.
-Just -- We'll get you --
Just two months,
we'll get you a present.
Yeah. This is great.
Alright, here we go.
-You're not supposed
to be friends
with your people
that you work with.
That's a work thing.
So she should have never
saw that shirt, sir.
Second answer -- block her ass.
And then, when she asks you
why you blocked her, said,
"Hey, you have mistaken me
for somebody else, sweetie.
I have -- You have a husband,
I've got a relationship.
You liked the picture
that I didn't have my shirt on.
I ain't like that."
-Wow. Alright.
-Y'all gotta get some gumption.
Start getting some gumption.
Start telling folks.
Stop acting like you're trying
to save somebody's feelings.
They wasn't saving
your feelings.
She wasn't thinking about
your feelings
when she liked the picture.
-Dude, I agree.
Shouldn't have liked it.
Alright, here, how about this?
-Okay, yes, you do,
but you confront him in
a restaurant full of people,
just in case you found out
his secret identity
and he try to choke you out
and kill you and bury you.
-Choke you out, yeah.
-So, that's --
Yeah, do it in public.
-Public place, yep.
-Don't confront him
while y'all watching TV.
He's going to kill you.
-[ Laughs ]
How about this?
-Okay, what you do is,
you be a real girlfriend.
First of all,
when you're in a relationship,
y'all supposed to
look out for each other.
Y'all supposed to have
each other's back.
You're not having his back
by letting him
going out and embarrassing
you and him in a damn crowd
with a terrible
Australian accent.
So, when he starts
doing it, say, "Stop that!
That's not funny!
Nobody likes that!
Stop doing that!"
Then, if he doesn't stop --
if he doesn't stop,
you break up with him
and start dating an Australian.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So every time now he see you,
you're with a real Australian.
-Uh-huh.
-So he can hear what
the accent sounds like.
-Yeah. And then point to your
boyfriend and you go,
"You think this is funny?"
-Hey, you think
he's pulling it off?
Is he pulling it off?
-Oh, my God.
-That is so stupid!
Why would you do that?!
That's dumb!
-Okay.
I can't wait to see you in
the next "Justice League."
I swear, I cannot wait.
I cannot wait to see it.
I just want to see the trailer.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, okay.
-Okay, I have two questions --
I have two answers for this.
'Cause this is
a sensitive thing.
The first question
I would have to ask is,
is she sure
she's not smelling herself?
Okay? First question.
-That's interesting.
-Okay, if it's the co-worker,
I'm very sensitive to this,
Jimmy, because I used to be
an athlete.
And I was a girl and, you know,
didn't really know
how to take care of myself.
So I didn't know to shave under
my arms and stuff like that.
Sometimes, I'm musty.
You know, if you get musty,
and it's embarrassing.
-Yeah, musty.
-You know, it's embarrassing.
So, what I would do is,
I would invite them into a room
and I would close the door.
And then the first thing I would
do is open up the window.
And I would let them see me
open up the window.
-Uh-huh.
-And if they say, "Why are you
opening up the window?",
I would be like,
"Because you stink."
And it's -- Because this is --
And let me tell you now,
that person's gonna appreciate
it, because all the [bleep]
that's been walking around
smelling him ain't said nothing.
That's like letting somebody
be in front of you
with a booger in their nose
and you're not saying,
"Hey, get that booger."
-Yeah, it's kind of --
Well, some people agree,
but, yeah, I think --
-You've got to tell them.
You've gotta tell them, Jimmy.
You've gotta tell them.
-But does it have to be me?
-Yes, because you're
the one that smells them.
-Mm...
-It's -- Wait a minute.
Oh, this is about
somebody you work with?
-No! No! I mean, no.
-Oh, I was finna say,
bring them out right now
so I can tell them.
-No, no. Yeah.
[ Laughs ]
That's why we're friends.
"Leslie,
you gotta do me a favor."
Yeah, yeah. No, no.
I don't know this person.
No, this is a fan.
But I just feel like, yeah,
if someone else can do that --
I don't know.
It's like you just go, "Hey --"
-Nah. The person that smells it
has got to be
the person that tells it.
-Did you know that rhymed?
-No, I didn't.
[ Both laugh ]
-Okay, here we go.
This one here is the last one.
-Get another [bleep] roommate!
What?!
No. What?!
-That's why we ask you.
We love you.
That is all the time we have
for "Life Coach."
My thanks to Leslie Jones.